Die Krankheit, über die wir heute sprechen,
betrifft weltweit 32 Prozent der Erwachsenen,
40 Prozent der Männer und etwa 25 Prozent
der Frauen. Und das Schlimmste ist:
Die meisten Betroffenen wissen gar nicht, dass sie
krank sind! Dabei leiden sie unter einem höheren
Risiko für Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen.
Und im fortgeschrittenen Stadium ist die
Krankheit inzwischen die häufigste Ursache für
Lebertransplantationen und Leberkrebs. Wie kann
eine so verbreitete Krankheit gleichzeitig so
unbekannt sein? Und was kann man dagegen tun?
Heute geht es um den Stoffwechsel, um Körperfett
und Ernährung. Übergewicht ist einer der
Risikofaktoren für diese Krankheit. Aber bevor du
jetzt denkst, dass dich das nicht betrifft – auch
jemand mit einem BMI im Normalbereich kann
diese Krankheit bekommen. Die neuesten
Forschungsergebnisse könnten dich dazu bringen,
dein Leben zu verändern. Deswegen haben wir die
Forscherinnen und Forscher besucht, die diese
Krankheit aufhalten wollen. Sie entwickeln mit
innovativen Geräten, Computermodellen,
Künstlicher Intelligenz und einer Menge
Pipetten eine Technologie, die ganz einfach Leben
retten kann. Und ich erklär’ euch jetzt wie.
Bevor wir uns die Krankheit im Detail anschauen,
machen wir nochmal einen Schritt zurück:
Wie und bei wem entwickelt sie sich? Wichtige
Risikofaktoren dafür sind Stoffwechselerkrankungen
wie Diabetes. Und auch Übergewicht ist mit einem
höheren Risiko verbunden. Aber die Entstehung
von Übergewicht ist echt komplex. Dazu haben wir
übrigens schon mal ein ganzes Video gemacht.
Klar, da spielen Ernährung und Bewegungsmangel
eine Rolle, aber längst nicht nur: Auch die
Erziehung, Gewohnheiten und die Psyche sind
entscheidend. Und ein weiterer Grund ist die
genetische Prädisposition. Früher war es natürlich
von Vorteil, wenn der Körper schnell Fettreserven
anlegt. Darum ist die genetische Veranlagung zum
Fettspeichern auch relativ weit verbreitet. Aber
heute ist die Veranlagung kein Vorteil mehr, weil
fett- und zuckerreiche Lebensmittel überall sind.
Der Konsum von diesen hochverarbeiteten Produkten
korreliert mit Übergewicht. Und die Zahlen
steigen: In Deutschland ist mittlerweile über die
Hälfte der Erwachsenen betroffen. Weltweit sind 13
Prozent adipös, also krankhaft übergewichtig.
Aber wie schon gesagt: Auch normalgewichtige
Menschen können die Krankheit bekommen. Und
auch hierbei spielen die Gene eine wichtige
Rolle. Trotzdem: Man ist auch mit der genetischen
Veranlagung nicht seinem Schicksal ausgeliefert.
Es ist nicht einmal besonders kompliziert,
diese Krankheit zu verhindern. Wie genau,
das erklären wir später im Video noch.
Besonders gefährlich ist es, wenn sich Fett
im Bauchraum anlagert. Dieses sogenannte viszerale
Fett umgibt die Organe, und kann sich sogar in den
Organen anlagern, zum Beispiel in der Leber.
Und genau da entsteht die Krankheit, über die
wir heute reden: Es geht um die so genannte
Fettleber. Die Leber ist das größte innere
Organ des Körpers. Sie ist eine Art Hauptbahnhof
für unseren Stoffwechsel: Alle vier Minuten filtert sie
das ganze Blut in deinem Körper! Die
Leber ist viel cooler, als ihr Ruf es vielleicht
vermuten lässt: Auch wenn über zwei Drittel
davon fehlen, zum Beispiel als Folge einer
Operation, kann sie sich noch regenerieren. Aber
unzerstörbar ist sie natürlich auch wieder nicht.
Okay, also wie entsteht so eine Fettleber?
Viele denken da zuerst an Alkohol. Und ja,
aufgrund von Alkohol kann es dazu kommen.
Aber das geht auch ganz ohne Alkohol:
Wenn die Leber zu viel Zucker bekommt, wandelt sie
diesen überschüssigen Zucker in Fett um und lagert
ihn in Fett-Tröpfchen ab. Eine nicht-alkoholische
Fettlebererkrankung entsteht.
Diese Krankheit wird abgekürzt auch einfach
„NAFLD" genannt. Aber trotz des Namens kann
sie auch bei Personen auftreten, die ein wenig
Alkohol trinken. Aber der ist dann eben nicht
ursächlich, denn die Fettleber entsteht dann
durch andere Stoffwechselprozesse. Sogar Kinder
und Jugendliche können davon betroffen sein!
Aber nur, weil Alkohol nicht an einer NAFLD
schuld ist, ist sie deswegen nicht weniger
gefährlich. Die schädliche Entwicklung in
der Leber ist zwar noch lange umkehrbar, aber
irgendwann wird ein Kipppunkt überschritten, an
dem die NAFLD sogar zu Leberkrebs führen kann.
Und bevor wir zur eigentlichen Forschung kommen,
müssen wir noch kurz verstehen, wie dieser Krebs
schlussendlich entsteht. Das liegt nämlich an
einer der – eigentlich tollen – Eigenschaften
der Leber, die ihr zum Verhängnis wird:
Wenn das Lebergewebe geschädigt wird, kann es
sich anfangs gut reparieren. Aber wenn es immer
wieder gereizt wird, kommt es zu Entzündungen
und zur Vernarbung. Sobald ein Großteil der
Leber vernarbt ist, spricht man von einer
Zirrhose. In diesem Zustand ist das Risiko
für Leberkrebs deutlich erhöht und die Leber
hat ihre Funktion fast verloren. Allerdings
kann dieser Zustand auch übersprungen werden. Die
Leber geht dann also direkt von der Verfettung
und der Entzündung zum Leberkrebs über.
[Prof. Klingmüller: Und dieser ständige Reiz,
diese ständigen Entzündungsvorgänge, die führen
dazu, dass dann immer wieder Zellen auch neu
gebildet werden müssen, also sich teilen.
Und diese Zellproliferation nennt man das,
die führt dann dazu, dass auch das Risiko immer
mehr steigt, dass Leberkrebs entstehen kann.]
Das ist Professor Ursula Klingmüller. Sie
forscht am Deutschen Krebsforschungszentrum
am Zusammenhang zwischen der NAFLD und Leberkrebs.
Gerade entwickelt sie mit ihrem Team ein Tool, mit
dem du schnell und einfach erfahren kannst, wie
hoch dein individuelles Leberkrebs-Risiko ist.
Professor Klingmüller und ihr Team
erforschen vor allem diesen zweiten,
also eher untypischen Weg zum Leberkrebs,
ohne eine Zirrhose als Zwischenstadium.
Diese Variante tritt zwar nur in einem kleinen
Teil der Fälle auf, aber weil so viele Personen
von einer NAFLD betroffen sind – ihr erinnert
euch, knapp ein Drittel der Menschheit – ist die
Zahl trotzdem nicht zu vernachlässigen.
Dafür untersuchen sie, wie der Krebs genau
entsteht und was dabei in den Zellen passiert.
Und da spielt ein Protein eine wichtige Rolle: Die
Entzündungsreize lösen Stress in den Leberzellen
aus. Darum schüttet der Körper HGF aus.
Das ist ein Wachstumsfaktor, ein spezielles
Protein. Das HGF dockt an die Leberzellen an,
die das Signal ins Innere der Zellen weitergeben,
ähnlich wie beim Domino-Effekt. Das wird auch
“Signalkaskade” genannt. Am Ende steht dann
die Zellteilung. HGF löst also über die
Signalkaskade aus, dass sich die Zelle teilt.
Aber was passiert jetzt, wenn viel Glucose,
also Zucker vorhanden ist? Das hat Christina
Mölders in der Petrischale untersucht. Sie ist
Doktorandin im Team von Professor Klingmüller.
[Christina Mölders: Ich habe Zellen in einer
Nährlösung gehalten, die viel Glucose hatte und in
einer Nährlösung, die wenig Glucose hatte und habe
dann wieder mit dem Wachstumsfaktor HGF stimuliert
und mir eben die Weitergabe von Signalen angeguckt
[...] Also wie proliferiert die Zelle, wächst die
Zelle oder kommt die zu einem Wachstumsstopp und
genau das habe ich mir in unserer angeguckt.]
Die Signalkaskade verändert sich also, wenn Zucker
verfügbar ist. Und dabei kann es passieren, dass
eine Zelle kontinuierlich das Signal bekommt, sich
zu teilen. Und je öfter das passiert, desto größer
ist die Chance, dass dabei Krebs entsteht.
Um aber ganz genau zu verstehen,
welcher Prozess durch was ausgelöst
wird, nutzt das Team diese krassen Geräte,
Computermodelle und Künstliche Intelligenz.
Zuerst werden Leberzellen von Patientinnen und
Patienten in verschiedenen Krankheitsstadien
untersucht. Dafür werden die Zellen aus
einer Probe aufgelöst, oder “lysiert”,
und dann mit so einem Massenspektrometer
untersucht. Das misst, welche Proteine in
welcher Menge in der Probe enthalten sind.
Wenn man diese Tests mit Zellen aus den
verschiedenen Proben über längere Zeit wiederholt,
kann man solche Kurven anfertigen. Daran lässt
sich erkennen, wie sich die Zusammensetzung
der Zelle über die Zeit im Krankheitsverlauf
verändert. Und daraus kann man dann schließen,
wie sich die Krankheit weiterentwickeln wird.
Hier kommt auch Künstliche Intelligenz
ins Spiel: KI ist besonders gut darin,
Muster zu erkennen. Aber Achtung! – das sind
letztendlich nur Korrelationen. Die Forscher
wollen aber natürlich auch die Mechanismen, also
die Zusammenhänge zwischen Ursache und Wirkung,
verstehen, zum Beispiel “Welches Protein löst
was aus?” Trotzdem unterstützt KI das Team dabei,
über alle Aspekte den Überblick zu behalten.
Das Ziel sind mathematische Modelle, mit denen
sich die Vorgänge besonders gut vorhersagen
lassen. Dafür muss das Team unter den vielen
Proteinen diejenigen finden, die schon früh auf
einen Leberkrebs hinweisen. Wenn man dann das Blut
von Patientinnen und Patienten untersucht, kann
man diese sogenannten Biomarker nachweisen und
damit den Krankheitsverlauf abschätzen.
[Prof. Klingmüller: Der Patient kommt,
es wird Blut abgenommen und wir wollen damit
testen, dann ganz einfach, ist das ein Patient,
der ein erhöhtes Risiko hat und das dann
der Arzt sagen kann, dieser Patient soll
möglicherweise in einem Jahr wiederkommen oder
in drei Monaten. Und er bräuchte jetzt eine
zusätzliche Untersuchung durch MRT oder CT, also
medizinische Bildgebung und so Patienten sozusagen
zuordnen und mit einer verbesserten
Vorsorgeuntersuchung versehen,
wenn sie es wirklich brauchen.]
Ok. Was bedeutet das jetzt genau? Naja,
das Tool wird komplett verändern, wie wir mit
NAFLD umgehen, von der Diagnose bis zur Therapie.
In schätzungsweise fünf Jahren kannst du beim
Blutabnehmen mit dem Biomarker-Test einfach dein
individuelles Risiko für Leberkrebs durch eine
NAFLD ermitteln lassen. Und dein Arzt kann dir
dann frühzeitig Hinweise zur Prävention geben.
Jetzt gerade kann dir kein Arzt der Welt sagen,
wie sich eine NAFLD verändern wird. Und
das finde ich mega krass! Wir leben in
der spannendsten Zeit der Menschheitsgeschichte,
in der wir einfach mit Künstlicher Intelligenz,
menschlicher Intelligenz und cooler
Forschung Leben retten! Geil. Go Science!
Mit dem Modell lässt sich dann voraussagen, wie
nah oder fern der Kipppunkt zum Leberkrebs noch
ist. Wenn alles entspannt ist, reicht es
vielleicht, einmal im Jahr die Leberwerte
zu kontrollieren. Wenn der Kipppunkt allerdings
schon kurz bevorsteht, wirst du häufiger und mit
verschiedenen Methoden untersucht – und das ist
die Zukunft: personalisierte Medizin. Weil so
viele von einer NAFLD betroffen sind, ist das
aber nur realistisch, wenn wir eine günstige,
schnelle Untersuchung haben. Und da ist ein
einfacher Bluttest ein riesiger Fortschritt
Okay, das war die Theorie. Jetzt zur Praxis.
Wie kann ich meine Leber schützen? Die Antwort
ist genauso simpel wie schwierig umsetzbar:
mit einem gesunden Lebensstil. Dadurch kannst
du Stoffwechselerkrankungen entgegenwirken
und damit auch einer NAFLD vorbeugen. In
der Praxis sieht das dann so aus:
[Christina Mölders: … dass man wirklich
versucht, Kleinigkeiten in seinen Alltag zu
integrieren, zum Beispiel, dass man einfach
mal häufiger die Treppe nutzt, anstatt immer mit
dem Aufzug zu fahren oder eben anstatt von süßen
Getränken dann einfach mal Wasser trinkt.]
[Prof. Klingmüller: Eine Möglichkeit, was man
machen kann, ist auch sich bewusst machen, diese
Snacks, die man sich angewöhnt hat, dass man am
Computer Chips, Kekse, Schokolade oder was stehen
hat und das so ziemlich unbewusst so ständig isst.
Das ist etwas, wo man sehr viel machen könnte,
denn der Körper ist an sich darauf eingestellt,
auch immer wieder Hungerperioden zu erleiden.]
Ob das bedeutet, dass man mal das Abendessen
auslässt, oder dass man ab und zu einen ganzen
Tag fastet, kann jeder individuell entscheiden.
Beides hilft dem Stoffwechsel und damit der
Leber. Übrigens: Die Kombi aus Fett und Zucker
ist besonders schädlich. Aber keine Sorge,
es ist völlig okay, mal etwas Fettiges oder
Süßes zu essen. Die Zeitspanne von der NAFLD zum
Leberkrebs beträgt mehrere Jahrzehnte. Trotzdem
ist es wichtig, der Leber auch mal eine Pause zu
gönnen. Und je früher man das auf dem Schirm hat,
desto kleiner sind die Einschränkungen
und die eventuellen Folgen. Und da die
meisten “Doktor Whatson”-Zuschauer relativ jung
sind, sind das gute Nachrichten für euch!
Es war mega spannend, die Labore zu besuchen
und vor Ort zu sehen, wie an Leberkrebs
geforscht wird. Und ich hoffe natürlich,
dass wir mit diesem Video dazu beitragen,
dass mehr Leute diese gefährliche, aber
vermeidbare Krankheit im Blick haben.
Fun Fact: Gerade wird in den gleichen Laboren
vom gleichen Team auch an Lungenkrebs, Leukämie
und dem Zusammenspiel von Leber, Lunge und Herz
geforscht. Die häufigsten Todesursachen weltweit
sind nämlich Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
und Krebs. Durch den interdisziplinären
Ansatz des Projekts werden Bereiche
zusammengebracht, die vorher fast nur
isoliert voneinander betrachtet wurden. Nice!
Das Projekt, das diese Forschung zur Fettleber
möglich macht, heißt SMART-NAFLD.
Wenn ihr mehr darüber erfahren wollt,
schaut euch die Links in der Beschreibung
an. Mit zwei weiteren Forschungsprojekten
zu Leberkrebs ergibt sich daraus das Netzwerk
LiSym-Krebs, das vom Bundesministerium für
Bildung und Forschung gefördert wird. Dieses
Video ist auch in Zusammenarbeit mit dem
BMBF und dem Projektträger Jülich entstanden.
Danke an das Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung. Danke an euch fürs Zuschauen. Bis zum
nächsten Mal, bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.